all of this guy is thinking about
politicians in this country who dare to
tell the truth and are attacked for it
and Kerry Lake was at the very top of
that list she's running for governor in
the state of Arizona and she joins us
tonight Kerry Lake thanks so much for
coming on so you were one of the very
first American politicians to weigh in
on this election you were paying
attention which I appreciated what do
you make of this
I'm so excited you know it's funny I
looked I looked this Italian Ms Maloney
up when I heard about her about a week
ago and I couldn't find any just
straight up information on her
everything was she's a fascist she's a a
racist she's this she's that and I
thought wow this is somebody who I can
relate to because they're doing the same
thing about me and it makes me realize
that if they're not calling you all of
these slurs if they're not attacking you
then you're probably not truly
representing the people of your country
but it's just so interesting that this
is a change if you're elected in Arizona
it will be a change Donald Trump was a
change the people who are rejected by
voters in this representative democracy
that we have never for one second learn
anything from that rejection why do you
think that is
I don't know I can't get into their
minds but I mean I think of the Marjorie
Taylor greens of the world the
congressman Paul gosars the Donald
Trumps of the world uh what's happening
in Italy myself the people who are truly
understanding what's happening in this
country which is we're losing this
country are the ones who are being
attacked and I you know I'm on the
campaign Trail we're working six to ten
events a day we're working really hard
and I had somebody reach out to me the
other day and say Carrie you are
fearless you are so Fearless what you're
not afraid of anything and I stopped him
and I said actually I have great fear
I'm not afraid of the fake news I'm not
afraid of the globalists I'm not afraid
of anything that I'm facing on the
campaign Trail not afraid of the cartels
what I'm scared to death of is what
happens if we don't step in right at
this moment and do something I'm afraid
of the world that our children will live
in that's what scares me to death
so you you spent your career working in
news so you know how totally fraudulent
uh it is it's a burden some of us bear
who work in this business maybe that's
why you're not afraid thank God for you
thank God for you because you know it's
fake truly Carrie Lake
godspeed thanks for joining us tonight
thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight